Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab, the podcast.
Okay. So a little while ago we were talking to our friend, right.
Am I on or do I send a regular guest? Steve Strogatz. Yeah, try that.
He's a math professor at Cornell. Talk out of the shot in my mouth. Shane.
He does have some mic positioning issues,
but he came to our studio because he wanted to tell us about something he'd
seen. It kind of made him go, Whoa, man.
And I just had all these funny deep thoughts and it had to do,
oddly enough.
[inaudible]
with a slinky. Yeah.
no, there's, I mean there's actually a little more of a story.
I don't know if you want to make it a real story. Yeah. Story it up there. Okay.
The real story is, I was in England, um, you know,
the past few months and there's this character,
like England is good with characters. They have these eccentric kind of guy.
So they have this eccentric physicist named Tadashi.
He was a philologist. He speaks like 12 languages.
Then you decided to be a physicist and not only is today she a multilingual
pseudo philologist turned physicist. He also likes magic. Yeah,
he's very good like a magician at entertaining little kids. And so, uh,
one day Steven,
his kids are having lunch with Tadashi and at some point during that lunch today
she turns to Steve's kids and he's like, Hey, you guys want to see a trick,
a magic trick. And he shows my kids, you know, here, you know what a slinky is.
Yes. The kids know. And then he holds out this slinky,
which is at first it's all compressed, you know, it's a tight coil.
Then he lets it the bottom stretch as much as it wants to,
but he's still holding onto at the top, you know, so it's all stretched out.
And then he says, now watch carefully. I'm going to let go of the top,
but watch the bottom. Watch closely. So he's holding it out.
The kids eyes are open wide and then he lets go.
It's like he falls to the ground. But the weird thing,
the unbelievable thing is that the bottom doesn't move at first.
The bottom doesn't go down. The bottom does not go down. He's held the top.
He released the top and the top starts to fall. But the bottom doesn't.
When you see the volume doesn't go down, what does that mean?
What does the bottom doing? You're just, the bottom is hovering in midair. No,
like a flying carpet. It's just sitting there, but not for long.
For a fraction of a second.
The bottom of the slinky seem to defy the laws of physics.
It looks impossible. Where are they now? Why is it put?
So what would we normally, what would we normally think this link should do?
That it would fall. It would all fall together for you. It's a coil.
So can you say the top is pulling on the bottom, holding it up? Well,
let's remember how we prepared it first. We let the slinky come to equilibrium.
We hold the top,
we will let the bottom stretch out as far as it wants to till everybody's happy.
It goes one and a damps itself out and sits there. Yeah.
Okay, so that means the bottom is at rest,
it's at rest because it's being pulled up just as hard as it's being pulled
down. It's being pulled up by the slinky,
by the tension in that slinky coil pulled down by gravity.
They're exactly matched. So it says, I'm cool. I'm here. I'm not going anywhere.
Now at the top,
the tension in the spring is pulling the top down as well as gravity is pulling
it down. The only thing holding it up, your fingers,
the fingers that the next thing that happens is the sinister magician.
Let's go of the top.
There are actually videos of this online where you can see people dropping
gigantic slinkies like a hundred feet long slinkies off of balconies,
and in the video they also slow the frame's way down.
So you can see everything that happens and here's what you see.
You see the top of the slinky,
the first coil for his turn collapses onto the turn just below it,
and then just below that one and just below that one,
and you can watch the thing collapse hitting towards the bottom. Meanwhile,
the bottom of the slinky is just hovering.
Even though the top has been let go,
the bottom doesn't know anything has happened. Wait what?
The bottom doesn't know that the top is free where we did the bottom doesn't
know where the verb knowing is throwing me. So let's,
here's the way that a physicist would talk about it is the bottom doesn't feel
anything except that little bit of metal right above it.
And as long as the little bit of metal right about hasn't changed in any way,
then the very bottom doesn't know that it's supposed to fall.
That is exactly right. There's these two ideas there.
There's a kind of physicsy idea about what the top is doing relative to the
bottom and then there's this concept of knowledge,
which is why I thought this would be fun to talk about cause we don't usually
think of things like slinkys as having information and knowledge. Hmm.
There's a con a much deeper meaning to the idea of information in the world
around us than we're used to thinking. And Steve says,
this goes way beyond slinkies when I drop a pen. In fact,
the bottom hovers for a few billions of a second while the top is falling and
compressing the pen, but it's all ha. Yeah, it really has to be like that.
When anything falls, it falls like a slinky.
Just the difference being does it so fast that you can ignore it.
By the way. Go ahead. Oh, you should know this. That's Neil.
I'm Neil degrasse Tyson and excitable physicist with the American Museum of
natural history.
We actually brought them this argument so we could find out what he thought.
I P I played with the slinky are too in my day. I mean,
it's my generation's toy. Right, and you never knew, however,
that there was this levitating thing.
I never knew about the levitating properties of the slinky.
After he thought about it for a bit,
he told me something surprising that there's an awesome consequence to the fact
that one part of an object has no idea what's going on in an adjacent part.
For example, and anti-tank warfare,
you want to get through armor or an armored tank,
you can fire a bullet into the side of the tank and the bullet flattens and puts
a little dink and nothing else happens. So what the military,
according to Neil, what they do, they shoot rods at the tank,
not bullets, rods. And why do they do that? Why do they do that?
If you shoot a rod, the first part of the rod hits the tank,
it gets pulverized.
But the second part of the rod does not know that yet.
It's waiting around for the wave to reach it.
So then the next piece hits and the next piece,
every molecule of that rod is hitting the tank without ever knowing that there
was a molecule in front of it that got vaporized. There's a bow and arrow.
Same thing with a bow and arrow. He says, if you can you take an Arrow in,
just use your your arm and shove it into a tree. No,
but with a bow, you can with a bow, a powerful enough bow,
you can fire an Arrow fast enough so that every segment of the Arrow doesn't
know that the front of the Arrow just hit something and it keeps pushing it.
It's, it's, so, in other words,
you think once the front of the Arrow hits something,
it slows down the whole Arrow. Yes. It's what I think. It doesn't,
the last bit of it hits it at the same speed that the front of it did.
The Arrow saying coming in, Oh God, next part coming in. Ooh, goes away.
It's coming here. Ooh. Sequentially. Straight in.
But now the next bit of Arrow comes in and gets further dig to get further dink
to Exxon. It just, it just keeps getting a bigger and bigger. So if you,
if you have a rod that is the length of 10 bullets,
that single rod is effectively 10 consecutive bullets hitting exactly the same
spot. So the military has exploited this fact,
this simple slinky fact that one part of the slinky has no clue what's going on
with the rest of it.
That's right. This is the nature of reality.
The slinky shows you how it really is,
so you're saying the slinky reveals something about the nature of everything.
There you go.
That's why I think it's so cool that what it's revealing is what physicists call
it locality.
All you can feel in this world and in this life is what's right on you.
What's right on your fingertips, what's right on your senses and you don't know.
I don't want to say what I want to say.
You don't know anything until the right wave hits you.
The example I like to think of is the sun. The Sun is there.
We feel its gravity. It's warm Fitz light.
If some cosmic force plucked the sun from the center of the solar system
instantaneously, we would have no clue.
We would continue to orbit this empty spot in space.
We would continue to feel sunlight and warn. When we see a glow,
you would see the sun for eight minutes even though it's not there because,
but you don't know. It's not there.
The edge of the way it hasn't reached you yet. The earth doesn't.
Nobody knows it for eight minutes and 20 seconds because eight minutes and 20
seconds after it's plucked from the center of the solar system,
your world goes dark,
it goes cold and earth flies away at a tangent to be lost forever in
interstellar space. Have a nice day.
Now this feels like an extraordinarily rich notion in some Greek tragic way or
something like you are. When something changes in your world,
you are faded to some kind of experience,
but you don't know it and yet it's inevitable. It's coming at you. Yes,
coming at you as the perfect way to think about it,
but what does this do to you to the thought that you are in charge of your own
experiences? If if it's just a time, it's just a time delay.
I mean you want to get philosophical and I and I respect that and your one month
you're a philosophical man about town but it's just a time delay.
I mean suppose it happened instantaneously.
They knew it happened now instead of a half a second from now.
What difference does it make to you? Well,
because I have a period of being in the dark that is in a,
later on I'll have knowledge that I was faded to a certain consequence and all
that time the rest of this thinking was coming at me, coming at me,
coming at me, coming at me, coming at me, coming at me,
coming at me and I had no idea. I was just innocent in my
end of sneakiness by the way, that happens all the time. For example,
the dinosaurs,
there was an asteroid headed their way and I'm not a last one of them knew about
it until it was too late. This happens all the time.
That makes it seem sort of matter of fact,
I being the man about town as you just described,
but think of this philosophical man like, yes,
I feel that there's something somewhat frightening about this notion as opposed
to just simply there. It's not my fault.
If your brain operates differently from the inevitability of something from not
knowing that it was going to happen at all. You are so calm about physical guy.
I'm not gonna you know I'm not going to scratch my head over this one. No.
If it's when you know about it, you know about it,
but you're anxious about something about to happen to you, but you don't know,
so you're going to worry about the thing that might've happened to you that you
don't know. I can't.
Life is too short for me to worry about something like a Jewish thing.
They had no control over. They don't, don't even know what happened.
Someone said if earth is going to be swallowed by a black hole or if there's
some disturbance in the space time continuum, should we worry about it?
No, because you won't know it until it crosses your, your place in space time.
So the life lesson here is like you live in your own tempo, you know,
and you get your beats and that's just it.
Your beats come to you when nature decides it's the right time. Yeah.
Be at the speed of sound, the speed of light, the speed of electrical impulses.
We will forever be victims of the time delay between information around us and
our capacity to receive it.
Yeah, that's it. That's the picture.
You're always the bottom of the slinky.
Big thanks to Steve Strogatz who is a professor of mathematics at Cornell
University. His new book is called
the big X. No, it's the joy of x or the joy of x,
which is like the joy of sex,
but it's missing the s in e and e and the sex and the sex.
But you get the last letter,
which is of course the only thing that really matters.
As many calculating couples have always said at the end, you know,
just before the cigarette.
I really like the x part and I think we all do it that it takes,
did Neil degrasse Tyson,
his latest book is called Space Chronicles facing the ultimate frontier and
things. Also, Matthew Kielty for production health.